Steve in our last episode about
reliability for serverless apps you
showed me how to implement smoke tests
yeah I saw there were some good
discussions in the comments
I feel like I'm on a roll here I only
spent about 15 minutes making my more
reliable using smoke tests and it felt
great what's the next baby step to make
my application even more reliable
let's add monitor
[Music]
Steve you told me the other day that you
have experience in reliability
engineering
that's right I was a site reliability
engineer or SRE inside of Google for
over a decade I worked on search Android
YouTube and Cloud now my job is helping
developers understand how to build
reliable systems on the cloud
excellent now why is monitoring needed
well we can't see code running inside a
CPU or bytes changing in memory when a
user reports an error it's hard to tell
what went wrong inside of this opaque
box so let's make that box transparent
how do we make it transparent
well when something breaks our first
thought is often I wish I had an x-ray
machine so I could see inside the system
we can build that x-ray machine ahead of
time by adding monitoring
I like that idea but Steve you know me
I'm all about taking small baby steps
how can I start to monitor my system
within the next five minutes my code
runs on cloudron
well Cloud run provides a dashboard with
some useful metrics right out of the box
let's start with that
okay
let me go to the cloud run section of
the cloud console when I click my
service here I get a page full of graphs
their chores for request rates request
latencies and the number of containers
Google has started up for me this gives
me a pretty good overview of my cloud
run service
well that was less than five minutes
right yeah it sure was but if my system
has a problem will the X-ray machine in
other words these charts uh tell me what
went wrong
well even the best x-ray machine in the
world needs a doctor to interpret these
results it's the same thing with
monitoring when an error is reported
monitoring will tell us what metrics
changed and that will give us a clue as
to what went wrong
okay so let's say a user reports an
error I would go to this dashboard and
look at the graphs
yeah let's say the response time graph
shows an increase around the same time
that a user reported the error we would
call that a symptom just like with a
doctor it would not tell you exactly
what is wrong which is what we call the
cause so it could be one of many causes
maybe the database queries are taking
longer or that application is
overwhelmed by a spike in traffic
and then I would at least know that I
should check the database queries or
that I should check the traffic volume
that's right the dashboard should point
you in the right direction telling you
where in the system those symptoms are
occurring and the more metrics you track
the more clues the dashboard will give
you about this cause of the problem
one more question I've seen systems
where these graphs were kind of spotty
because the application only executed
when someone visited the website
yeah many systems are like that in our
previous episode we talked about smoke
tests if you run these smoke tests
regularly the graphs will have some more
data and you'll get a better sense of
your system's Health even when users
aren't around
I like that that would also mean that if
something breaks at 5 PM right after
people have stopped using the system for
the day I would learn about it right
away
yes you would and you wouldn't have to
wait until a user hits the error say the
next morning
that makes sense but there are a lot of
things my application does that's not
covered by these default Cloud run
metrics for example it calls the YouTube
API and I'd like to see those calls in a
dashboard too
well you wanted the five minute version
do you have some more time
well you haven't steered me wrong yet
Steve I'd be happy to invest some more
time building a better x-ray machine for
my system
okay the next level would be to add some
custom metrics that are specific to your
application your application code is
probably writing logs already we can
convert those existing log messages to
metrics that we can graph
got it every time the YouTube API
returns an error my code writes a
message like this to the log
great we can create a useful metric from
that first pull up the log entries that
match that text
then create a counter metric this will
tell us how often this entry appears in
the logs if the rate of this counter
goes up there may be a problem in the
system
oh okay I'll enter a name for the metric
then I click create metric
uh looks like an I can explore the new
metric here I'll click that
there isn't any data yet but I will save
the chart
I'll put it in a new dashboard
done
all right well does your application
write any other log messages
well every time a user opens the web
page a pretty heavy database query runs
to find the videos that they subscribe
to and the code is triggered by a get
request to this endpoint
okay we can create a distribution metric
from that this will let us create
percentile latency graphs for example if
we see that the 95th percentile for
database queries is 100 milliseconds
that means that 95 of queries took 100
milliseconds or less
why don't we just measure the average
time
well using an average would hide a lot
of the interesting characteristics of
your system which would prevent us from
learning more about it response times
tend to vary a lot some responses are
very fast and others very slow they
might have extreme outliers which would
be totally hidden from view if we use
the average these are actually the cases
that we care about the most so let's not
hide them
and that's where percentiles come in
yeah we can use percentiles to better
visualize the distribution this gives us
a view over time of the shape of the
distribution like how slow or the
slowest and how fast were the fastest
and how does user experience play into
these percentiles
what we really want to know is how many
requests were too slow for this we need
a cutoff value let's say one second
would be fast enough for a user not to
be frustrated in this case we will
simply count the number of requests that
take more than one second we will use
these in something called an SLI a
service level indicator which would be
used to alert an operator to step in and
fix something
sounds good I'll pull up the matching
log entries like before in the log
Explorer
then I'll click create metric
I'll click here to explore the metric
then I will save the chart
I'll pick the dashboard I created before
there let's look at my new dashboard
all right now you have the built-in
Cloud run dashboard with all the
standard metrics plus this new dashboard
with custom metrics for your application
let's leave it for a few hours so the
graphs can fill up with data
and we're back Steve uh I had some use
of the dashboard
oh what happened
a user reported that the data in the
application didn't seem fresh
and you used your two dashboards
yes first I looked in the built-in Cloud
run dashboard there were no errors or
changes in latency it looked like the
cloud run service wasn't throwing
exceptions so probably not anything
broken in Cloud run
so then you checked the dashboard with
the custom metrics
exactly the application has two major
Integrations the YouTube API and the
database we created one metric for each
and I needed to find out which one was
breaking
yeah it really helps if you know which
part of the system is causing problems
because you can't troubleshoot
everything at once
right the database latency had not
changed so I figured it probably wasn't
a database problem then I saw this in
the YouTube error graph it looks like a
problem with the calls to the YouTube
API now that I knew what to look for I
could check the logs in more detail and
it turns out to be the new code that I
released that sometimes didn't ask
YouTube the YouTube API for all the
right Fields it was a quick fix
well it's good to hear that your
application is working again uh was
there something more that you wish you
had tracked
yes I started tracking this particular
error as a new metric so if that metric
spikes I know that I started sending bad
requests to YouTube again
this is often the pattern as new errors
appear we learn more about the system
and we become better at monitoring it
all right you've spent maybe 15 minutes
and you already have dashboards that
will give you valuable Clues if there is
an outage agreed what might I want to
monitor next Steve
it's always interesting to measure the
user experience how long does the user
have to wait how many arrows do they see
how fresh is the data sent to them and
so on the more you can measure the user
experience the more you can collaborate
with other teams in your organization
your dashboard may even become a
valuable tool for discussions between
engineers and business people
ah so to recap a viewers should first
familiarize themselves with the built-in
metrics they can be useful when
troubleshooting problems
then they can create custom metrics
based on existing logging from the
application
and finally they may want to add metrics
about the user experience
that's right if you do all that both
your applications and your organization
will be in a better place
great thank you for that Insight Steve
and thank you everyone for watching if
you have any questions for Steve or me
add them in the comments also let me
know if there are other serverless
topics you would like to see in future
episodes
I read every single comment until next
time
[Music]
thank you